à mon avis personnel c'est une
aberration parce qu'on peut consommer
ainsi rester pendant une demi heure ne
pas consommer de vous voir un café en 2
minutes 40 et du comptoir qui doit
s'asseoir ne veut pas forcément
s'asseoir et les gens préféreront rester
chez eux ou rentrer directement et pour
partir plus tard le matin et éviter car
dans le café je trouve ça bien parce que
comme ça tout le monde sait respecter la
verve ça c'est bien comme ça les gens me
sens pas plus ensemble et ça ça paraît
donc le moral c'est bien moi ça me fait
beaucoup rire en fait tout ça mais je
trouve que c'est avancer reculer avancer
on fait trois pas en avant deux pas en
arrière et c'est pas une nouvelle mesure
ces mesures qu'on avait déjà mis en
place qu'on ait du mal à faire intégrer
à nos clients et maintenant bas il faut
recommencer donc on a du mal à repartir
on a du mal à comprendre tout ce qui se
passe parce que enfin les mesures
changent tout le temps l'existence elle
change les jo je change et faire
comprendre ça à la clientèle c'est juste
pas possible en fait